all right well you know you already know
if you don't know what we're starting
five headlines with today then you are
not a real fan of this show
um and uh it it why are we starting with
it because it's big news I mean actually
big groundbreaking
should be earth-shattering news a
website called the the debrief
um has a report this week actually just
came out yesterday
with this headline
intelligence officials say U.S has
retrieved craft of non-human origin
okay now I want you to to listen to this
and you're going to listen to it so sit
down and listen all of you damn it
um and care about it you listen to it
and care because this is important
uh reading a little bit says a Former
Intelligence official turned
whistleblower has given Congress an
intelligence Community Inspector General
extensive classified information about
deeply covert programs that he says
possess retrieved intact and partially
intact craft of non-human origin the
information he says has been illegally
withheld from Congress and he filed a
complaint alleging that he suffered
illegal retaliation for his confidential
disclosures reported here for the first
time other intelligence officials both
active and retired with knowledge of
these programs through their work in
various agencies have independently
provided similar corroborating
information both on and off the Record
The Whistleblower David Charles grush 36
a decorated former combat officer in
Afghanistan is a veteran of the National
geospatial Intelligence Agency and the
national reconnaissance office
he served as the reconnaissance officers
representative to the unidentified
aerial phenomena task force from 2019 to
2021 from late 2021 to July 2022 he was
the nga's co-lead for UAP analysis and
its representatives to the task force
so this is a high-ranking person and all
by the way all of his credentials have
been verified so it's not just some you
know Looney Tune making this up
um yeah the credential part we know for
sure so he was involved in these
programs at the very top
privy to like the most classified kinds
of information and this is what he's now
telling us
the task force was established to
investigate what were once called
unidentified flying objects or UFOs and
are now officially called unidentified
anomalous phenomena or UAP
the task force was led by the department
of the Navy under the office of the
under secretary of defense for
intelligence security it has since been
reorganized and expanded into the
all-domain anomaly resolution office or
Arrow to include investigations of
objects operating underwater
gross said the recoveries of partial
fragments through and up to intact fuels
vehicles have been made for decades
through present day by the government
its allies and defense contractors
analysis has determined that the objects
retrieved are of exotic origin based on
the vehicle morphologies and material
science Testing and the possession of
unique Atomic arrangements and
radiological signatures
in filing his complaint grush is
represented by a lawyer who served as
the original intelligence Community
Inspector General
Russ says we're not talking about
prosaic origins or identities the
material includes intact and partially
intact vehicles
now
let's see there's a lot to this report
and uh
you could read the entire thing in fact
you should you should go read the entire
thing a lot more to the story but that's
like that's the really basic gist of it
and it's incredible we have it goes on
to explain that it's not just this guy
there are multiple whistleblowers
confirming the existence of alien
spacecraft this is the kind of thing
that's never happened before where they
come out and say yes it's real yes we
have it yes it's from non-human origin
and they've been recovered and studied
for years for decades
but yet of course somehow this like
barely even makes a dent it Trends so
this story was trending on Twitter
anyway yesterday but uh but somehow it's
not treated as major headline news which
obviously it is
and actually there's more to it this
whistleblower had an exclusive interview
on news Nation last night which I can
tell you that is a 10-minute segment
again well worth watching go to news
Nation go to the YouTube channel they
have it up
um I I tell you I I gathered uh my
entire family in fact I got my kids my
kids had gone to bed and I had them come
out of their rooms
because I because someone sent me this I
didn't know the guy did an interview on
news nation and uh and so my kids came
out of their rooms after they'd already
go in bed so we all and I got my wife uh
to gather around and I said look you
know come on kids we're gonna come on
family it's a family moment we're gonna
watch this interview you're gonna
remember this moment for the rest of
your life and we watched the interview
and they were bored by it like they
didn't even care my wife started
wandering away in the middle of it I
said where are you going this it's only
10 minutes can you spare 10 minutes
to learn about aliens
um I won't subject you to 10 minutes but
here's one minute
with some additional information about
what this guy says the government has
recovered listen
if you're right if you're telling us the
truth
everyone the entire American public has
been lied to for decades yeah there's a
sophisticated uh disinformation campaign
targeting the U.S populace which is
extremely unethical and immoral you are
saying
to the human race for the first time
an official
intelligence representative at a high
level from the US government is saying
publicly
we are not alone we're definitely not
alone absolutely the data points
empirically that we're not alone yeah do
we have bodies do we have species both
well naturally when you recover
something that's either landed or
crashed
um
sometimes you encounter dead pilots and
believe it or not as fan as Fantastical
as that sounds
it's true
so that he's saying that we not only
have the vehicles that they actually
have
actual extraterrestrial aliens in their
possession
now
um
let me answer a few objectives there are
objections that are raised objections
raised uh by people very close to me
like for example my own wife my
co-workers here I am we're not alone in
the universe but I
feel alone sometimes as a UFO Enthusiast
especially working here so uh in
objections right but the real the real
objection people have I think is that
they just like they rule it out as a
possibility because they don't want to
think about the implications if it's
true I think that's the actually what's
going on and we'll get to that in a
second but
um so there's the real objection which
is that there are people especially some
conservatives who think that like I
can't believe this I just can't not that
it's unbelievable but I just I can't
allow myself to believe it because I
think it has implications that are scary
to me
um but that's not usually what's said
instead it's something you know there
are they cite other reasons and one of
them is that this is a distraction by
the government does trying to distract
us that's all this is but that's
nonsense first of all because these
stories don't get a lot of attention
right they they get some attention but
they're not they're not um it's not
something that dominates the news cycle
for days on end most many people don't
care that much
so they should care I think but they
don't so the describe the distraction
theory is totally baseless it makes no
sense it's not a distraction people
don't focus on it that much
um not to mention the whole idea that
the government would need to invent
these kinds of stories to distract us
like we're distracted all the time
anyway by a million different things so
they need to come up with some totally
outlandish
story about aliens that they've
recovered to distract us when we're all
ready I mean most people they spend 10
hours a day just like scrolling randomly
through Tick Tock and watching Netflix
you think that the American public needs
to be distracted by this
it's like you're flattering us okay as
if we're all you know laser focused on
the important issues and so they have to
come up with some crazy distraction
mechanism uh that's not the case I wish
it was but it's not are you tired of
waiting ages for your grill to heat up
now you can say goodbye to those tedious
moments of impatiently watching the
charcoal burn and say hello to instant
barbecue Perfection thanks to our new
friends at uh and they're very good
friends already because they gave me one
of these our friends at Grill Blazer
Grill Blazers Grill guns are designed to
do everything from expertly searing your
Meats to lighting charcoal grills wood
stoves outdoor fireplaces and just about
anything else you can think of uh with
high power fire to solve your problem
Grill Blazers offers two types of Grill
guns the grill gun basic is a high power
propane torch designed to Light charcoal
and wood grills and smoke and smokers
and burns up to 3 600 Degrees it's 30
inch flame is for anything you need a
big bad torch to do and the sous vide
gun has as a shorter Barrel which I
believe is what I have here
perfect for professional Culinary
Kitchen user uses from gently
caramelizing brulee or other sugar
fruits to rapidly searing steaks outside
on the grill using the grill gun may
result in extreme Grill Envy from your
neighbors and increase demands for
barbecue parties they handed this thing
to me and I was just informed that
this thing is this thing is ready to go
so if I think if I pull this trigger it
fire will shoot out and I was told not
to pull the trigger let's find out what
happened so we know what happens if you
grill if you use this in your kitchen
what if I grill that TV over there what
will happen we could find that out
together
I'm finding it very difficult to
exercise Trigger Discipline with this
thing like the the temptation just I
really just want to pull the trigger and
see what happens no no I'm being told no
the white hammy one that's loaded this
thing is ready you know like don't put
the tank the propane tank on it
anyway uh get your grill gun from Grill
Blazers today and let the grilling
Adventures begin visit grillblazer.com
Walsh and use promo code Walsh for 15
off your order that's
grillblazer.com
Walsh promo code Walsh for 15 off your
order
yeah at most this is just like a side
show people treat it like a sideshow and
if the government wanted to throw out
minor Sideshow things they don't have to
go all the way to aliens so the theory
doesn't make any sense also if your
argument against these stories is that
you don't trust the government well for
decades the government denied all of
this they lied to us they made up all
kinds of ludicrous explanations for
these phenomena now you're just
parroting what the government has said
for decades the intelligence community
on the record for decades and said no
there's nothing going on everything's
fine everything's cool
so who's the one trusting the government
here
besides these are mostly whistleblowers
telling us about this these are not
official government agencies in fact the
Pentagon came out with official
statement denying this
so you can believe the Whistleblower or
you could believe the official statement
from the Pentagon and if you're
skeptical of the government which one
are you going to trust you're skeptical
of government so you trust their
official statement and not the
Whistleblower who gains Nothing by
saying this he destroys his entire
career potentially puts himself you know
who knows he could be prosecuted knows
what they're going to do so like if if
skepticism of government is one of your
primary motivating uh things which I
totally understand
then that should lead you to uh lending
some credibility to this
um you know I've also heard the theory
in fact I was just talking to uh Michael
Knowles about this in uh in wardrobe and
he he was uh speculating was a misdirect
this could be a misdirection right
because really this is uh this is our
own Tech and that people are seeing and
we're claiming aliens so that China
doesn't know or whoever one of our
adversaries doesn't know that we have
this technology but that makes no sense
as I explained to him uh just a few
minutes ago
because they also are saying this
whistleblower sayings other countries
have recovered this stuff too so China
would know
if the alien story is totally made up
like you're not going to misdirect them
they know if it's true or not
so the idea that we're trying to fool
our adversaries who also have high level
classified information of their own and
we're trying to fool them by making up a
story about aliens to me is is uh is
ridiculous
now then there's the question of
evidence and there are some people who
say
he asked for 10 minutes into it we're
still talking about this uh
there are people who say well this isn't
it's not enough evidence
it's just hearsay right
well you got to take the whole picture
into account this is just the latest
whistleblower somebody very high up on
the Chain who as far as I can tell
stands to gain nothing
from this
um who had access to very classified
information
verified by other officials denied
officially by the Pentagon
but it's the latest in a chain of events
that includes all kinds of sightings I
mean thousands of them accompanied by
photographic and video evidence radar
it's been going back uh you know there
was many famous studies going back years
and years and years going back decades
but there was the famous sighting I
think they covered in uh um Unsolved
Mysteries the latest Unsolved Mysteries
series on on Netflix in Michigan
where hundreds of people
saw these things
simultaneously and were calling in we
have the 911 reports of them calling in
reporting what sound very much like
flying saucers and um
and it was caught on radar by the
national weather service at the same
time so many things like that so you've
got eyewitnesses you've got classified
information you've got physical evidence
you do have videos we have radar there's
actually a lot of evidence here
which makes so if if it's still not
enough for you to even entertain the
possibility then I have to ask you what
do you need
if this isn't enough to even make you
pause to think about it then what
evidence do you need what that tells me
is that there is no evidence that you
could ever be presented that would
convince you I think that is the case
for some people like you could literally
see them land right in front of you and
you would still say oh it's AI it's a
bit it's mind control it's like you
would go to any other explanation
but that
and I think that's because there's a
large portion especially of
conservatives who uh think because
conservatives tend to be more religious
you know and um who think that they
can't believe this because it would call
their faith into question but that's not
true let me let me relieve you of that
burden
um there's there's nothing about the
potential existence of life elsewhere in
the universe
that would call your faith into question
is it just we know the universe is
massive and there's lots of things going
on in the universe we don't know about
um and we probably can't even understand
because God has created a universe that
is much bigger and more complicated and
uh more amazing than maybe you give it
credit for I don't see how that that
calls anything now it raises questions
that we can't we can't answer all the
phrases all kinds of questions religious
questions scientific questions that we
can't answer because some of this stuff
is above our pay grade
but who says we have to understand every
last thing we have to be able to
understand every last thing about the
universe
you know as far as the Bible goes the
Bible is isn't concerned with talking
about what's happening elsewhere in the
universe
doesn't acknowledge like other planets
at all really
doesn't mean it denies they exist it's
just it's it's focused on what's
Happening Here
so I don't think that that's a concern
you need to have but I do think that
that is really the fundamental reason
why many people refuse to even look at
the evidence because they think that
they are committed
to not believing it and I and I think
that that's just not true you can you
can be open-minded
look at the evidence
and at least
acknowledge
that again the universe is a bigger and
more complicated place than than any of
us could possibly understand and there
are just there are putting aliens aside
there are things happening out there in
the vast Cosmos that we can't eat we
can't possibly wrap our minds around
um all right
that's my pitch
at least I didn't start the show that I
was very close
to making this the lead story of the
show I probably should have if you'd
like to see what else I have to say you
can access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed